cast your mind back if you would to 10
year old you
going to shirley oaks homes what was it
like living there
well the home itself and its
surroundings were fine no problem with
that whatsoever but it was an
absolute viper's nest or a snake pit of
pedophilia
and of course i didn't realize that at
the time but it's become
very apparent since so much went on
there
just unbelievable because you were so
young and because people were being
sexually assaulted all over the place
sorry sorry to get across your
philippines because you were so because
you were so young there's obviously a
bit of delay on the line
because you were so young and you know
you know you've never been to a home
before
you didn't report what had happened to
you you you apparently just thought that
this was was what happened in care homes
exactly how did you get over that as a
ten year old and it was full of young
people
and some were a bit older of course but
on the whole they were fairly young
people
and you just assume that it must be
normal i've never seen this kind of
behavior before
but there we go that's what happens in
these places
so what made you finally reveal what had
happened to you
all these years later
well it's taken 60 years basically
but i learned that the
rotherham girls the young girls in
rotherham were badly abused in a couple
of other places which became television
news
i was looking at that one newscast and i
thought wow i mean if those girls have
got the nerve to go forward and defend
themselves in court
i should really support them and sort of
use the responsibilities i've now got as
an older person
and as a grandfather to help anyone in
that position
so i admire those girls and my first
step was go
to shirley oaks which was a lucky find
really
because i couldn't find remember the
name shirley
but i always thought it was shirley
heights which was the name of a derby
winner
that i had a bet on one day later on in
life but
but in fact google changed the way it's
presented
the the findings it said others you
might like to search and one of them was
shirley oaks came up
and i recognized it straight away then
i've been making a mistake in the name
and that got me in our phone so so their
survivors association
they're tremendously helpful they
advised me that the first step to take
was to the local police station
and to file a complaint that takes a lot
of nerve you know
you've got to admire his children to do
that i'm now
76 it doesn't it's not a lot of nerve
for me but it's not something
really you want to talk about too much
but anyhow i went to the police station
they took a statement
i was just saying you obviously you know
it's not something you wanted to talk
about your whole life but
the fact that you've kept it very
doesn't necessarily mean that it hasn't
had an effect on you what what impact
has it had on your life
oh it's had a tremendous effect it's
very hard to quantify it really
i lost all my schooling when i left the
home because i wouldn't go to school
i had what's now known as school phobia
but no one knew why because i wouldn't
tell anyone
i refused to go to school lost my
tertiary education
and during those school days when i
would just nip across a playground over
the back wall and out of school i would
not attend school
and i became just streetwise basically
for years
and in a way that's helped me in good
stead later on in life but that's the
way it was then
what do you know about the person that
abused you
well the police told me later that and i
have to say before i go into that the
police
the two policemen that helped me were
tremendously helpful
i think scotland yard in the background
wasn't quite so helpful i'm sure they
really messed up big time
at one point not with me but with sosa
but
what helped me was that they believed
what i was saying the policeman had had
a similar experience himself and it was
a child abuse unit
they put me in touch with the historic
child abuse unit in scotland yard
they came down and uh began to work with
me
and eventually found out that or i found
out that i wasn't the only one that had
been abused by this guy there have been
literally dozens of them
and he gone off to just after i left
shirley oaks i went back home
the guy had gone off to ceylon to a
children's home there
where i've absolutely no doubt he
continued to abuse children out there
but later on here died so that was
effectively the end of the case as far
as scotland yard were concerned for me
but what i've been saying to them was
corroborated by other people
and that's quite important so personally
my experience with the police was
they were very very helpful the two um
unbelievably helpful
but i noticed a big background story
going on here
where one policeman before my case was
told not to investigate other police and
we learned that from a whistleblower
within shirley oaks
who was a great help so that needs to be
exposed properly
and it should be a forensic
investigation a criminal investigation
into what actually went on there a young
guy
died you know he had a family had
friends it must have terrified the other
kids in the home there
i didn't know about that case at the
time but looking back
the way it's been handled is disgraceful
i mean the policeman concerned is
probably living on the costa del sol
with
a lot of other criminals that came out
of the police forces and the crime
squads
in the 1960s and 70s which again we've
seen on television recently anyhow
but it's an absolute viper's pit yeah i
mean
that is something that the inquiry has
called for potentially a criminal
investigation into this
i mean obviously uh we don't know the
full facts around it as yet and that
would
also be the subject of any legal case um
just in terms of yourself you've had a
letter of apology from the council
you've been given a sum of compensation
does that in any way redress what
happened to you is there anything else
that could be done
to make things good no
not none whatsoever i mean the money's
sitting in the bank it'll be left to the
children later on when i die presumably
and the letter of apology was
meaningless it was a well-written letter
i can say that
but it's totally meaningless to me what
happened happened
and that hasn't yet been dealt with
properly for the other children in the
care home not just me
there was hundreds of children went
through that system we owe it to them
to investigate it properly and that
should be done in full
consultation with sosa who have been
working on this case for years and years
have been frustrated by lambeth borough
council and the police
it's about time they got it put together
properly we